[MUSIC PLAYING]
- So it's really a privilege
to be up here this afternoon.
I want to first thank Meredith.
I'm going to get
emotional about this.
Meredith has spent so much
time crafting the introductions
for each and every fellow
before their presentations.
And I think it is just
but one expression
of her incredible
kindness, generosity,
and also brilliance.
And I want to thank the
Joy Foundation as well
for supporting my
fellowship this year.
And I want to thank my
two research partners--
that I know one's
definitely in the audience--
Diana Myers, and also
Katherine [INAUDIBLE]
as well, for your just
incredible, intelligent
engagement with my research.
And I also want to
thank my fellow fellows.
And I see you all
out in the audience.
My conversations with
you, but also more,
I feel like just
learning from you
has opened up so many
new, exciting vistas
of inquiry for me,
and challenged me
in so many numerous ways.
I also want to give a special
shout out to my family.
And they're all over here.
So they have traveled incredible
distances to be here with me
this afternoon to support me.
And I'm just so grateful for
their presence this afternoon.
And last, but
certainly not least,
I want to thank my
partner, Eric, and just
for all of the incredible
ways that he supports me.
In my talk this
afternoon I'll talk
about how manuscripts are the
sine qua non of my research.
And Eric is the sine
qua non of my life
and so I'm thankful for him.
All right.
Enough of that.
Just over a month ago the
seemingly impossible happened,
news about a medieval
nun went viral.
On Wednesday, January 9th,
the journal Science Advances
published online an article in
which the investigators claimed
that they had found tiny
bits of blue pigment embedded
within the dental calculus,
or the calcified tooth
tartar of a 40 to
60-year-old nun who
lived sometime between 997 and
1162 CE at a monastic complex
at Dalheim, Germany.
Microscopic analysis
of the tartar
reveal that the blue pigment
was lapis lazuli derived
ultramarine.
It was by far the
most expensive form
of blue pigment used in
medieval works of art
because it was mined from a
single region in Afghanistan,
and thus a luxury trade good.
Within the context of
medieval book production,
ultramarine, like
gold and silver leaf,
was reserved for deluxe codices,
and only highly trained artists
were entrusted with its care.
Anita Radini, an archaeologist
at the University
of York in England and the
study's principal investigator
was initially dumbfounded
by the discovery.
She consulted archaeologists,
anthropologists, biologists,
and historians with
relevant expertise
to assess the significance
of her findings.
They determined that the
most likely explanation
for the presence of
the ultramarine pigment
in the nuns teeth
was either that she
was an illuminator in her
community's scriptorium
who used to lick her
brush to make a fine point
or that she was
responsible for preparing
the pigments for her
own use and/or the use
of other illuminations
in her community.
If true, these
conclusions present
another significant challenge
to the long held assumption
that monks rather than nuns were
the primary producers of books
throughout the Middle Ages.
Moreover, the research
methods employed in the study
offer a new approach
to recovering
the histories of medieval nuns
in their lived totalities.
As the investigators
note, identifying
the early contributions
of religious women
to medieval book
production, especially
before the 12th
century, is challenging
due to the limited number
of surviving books,
the precarious documentation
of women's communities,
and the tendency of scribes
to leave their works unsigned.
Among books in women's monastic
libraries, fewer than 15%
bear the names of
women or titles.
And before the 12th century
fewer than 1% of books
can be attributed to women.
As a result, individual female
scribes remain poorly visible
in the historical
record, and it is likely
that most of their scribal
work has gone unrecognized.
Thanks to the efforts
of these investigators,
the artistic and literary
contributions of medieval nuns
are now receiving
the public attention
they so richly deserve.
On the very day when
Science Advances published
the investigators
article, it was picked up
by major news outlets from
CNN to The New York Times
to NPR to the Atlantic.
And within 24 hours
of the news breaking,
I received excited emails from
my fellow Red Cliff fellows
and also staff at the institute
with links to these articles.
Of course, I was delighted to
see that this discovery was
generating so much interest.
But I must confess
that like medievalists
who were following the
story, including some
of the investigators
behind the study,
I was also frustrated by
some of the headlines.
Particularly by
those that proclaimed
that this finding
had the potential
to rewrite the history
of medieval nuns
or that it was shedding light
on some long forgotten history
of these women.
Such proclamations outright
to conceal or ignore
the important research
that has been undertaken
over the past 30 years to
find evidence of nuns working
as artists and scribes.
Notable examples of such
efforts include the monographs
by Harvard's own Jeffrey
Hamburger in 1997
and by Allison Beach in 2004.
For many medievalists
then the discovery
of a medieval nun with
ultramarine pigment embedded
in the tartar of her
teeth was not surprising.
It presents new
archaeological methods
for providing further
proof of what is already
known about medieval nuns.
These methods will undoubtedly
become indispensable additions
to the toolkit that
scholars have already
been using to identify
nuns' artistic and scribal
productions.
The burden of proving
that nuns possess
the requisite literacies
and skills to undertake
such productions on their own
is still much, much higher
than it is for monks.
And the existence of the remains
of a nun with ultramarine
in her teeth appears
to many to provide
the very concrete, credible,
nay irrefutable proof needed
to satisfy this
inequitable obligation.
Old assumptions about
these women as uneducated
or illiterate or
unskilled die hard,
even among scholars who
should know better, but don't.
Perhaps because of some sexist
preoccupation about the past
and possibly the present too.
Recovering evidence that nuns
worked as scribes and artists
has always been an essential
facet of my research
on the liturgical practices
of their communities.
In my forthcoming book,
which Meredith so graciously
introduced, The Care of Nuns--
The Ministries of
Benedictine Women in England
During the Central
Middle Ages, I
reconstruct the liturgical roles
that Benedictine women perform
from roughly 900 to 1200
through close palaeographical,
codicological, and textual
analysis of their extant books.
And in my current
project, Liturgy Matters,
Benedictine Women's Communities
in Medieval England,
I expand upon the
research of my first book
to examine more comprehensively
the materiality of Benedictine
nuns liturgical practices.
This turn to
materiality was inspired
by recent theorists
of religion who
have sought to understand
how and why humans choose,
transport, repurpose,
and consume
objects for sacred ends.
They argue that
religionists are not
so much believers as
technologists, who transform
and are transformed
by select objects
through sensual engagement.
Humans do not solely possess
the powers to speak, remind,
surprise, enchant, disgust,
heal, and harm, objects do too.
And scholars and
practitioners of religion
must reckon with their powers.
In my current book project,
I take up this charge
by reviewing medieval
nuns as technologists
through the objects
they created, acquired,
and treasured for
liturgical use.
Most of these objects
no longer survive
due to their natural
ephemerality,
their inevitable obsolescence
through frequent use and ritual
innovation, or their
destruction, appropriation,
or migration during and after
Henry VIII's dissolution
of all religious houses in
England, Wales, and Ireland
between 1536 and 1540.
Still, nuns liturgical
books supply important clues
for reconstructing,
even if only partially,
the features and uses
of these objects.
Nuns liturgical books
then are the sine qua non
of my research.
And not just because
of the limitations
posed by the surviving
material evidence,
but more importantly,
because these books served
as the primary matter
of nuns liturgies.
Without them, nuns
could not have
performed their daily
liturgical practices.
It would have been
impossible for them
to remember all of the prayers,
readings, chants, and actions
that were proper to the masses.
Eight hours of sung
prayer that constituted
the divine office
and the other rituals
that they enacted
every single day.
On account of the
indispensability
of books to nuns individual
and corporate realization
of their vocations as valid
religious precious materials
and extensive labor were often
dedicated to books production
and they were then stored
and used with great care
to ensure their
integrity and durability.
Some books, depending
on the circumstances
surrounding their
making and handling,
were even venerated as relics.
Prominently displayed on
the altars of nuns churches
or buried with cherished
members of the community.
All of the extent liturgical
books from communities
of Benedictine nuns
in medieval England
bear telling signs of their
production, circulation,
and application from
marginalia to drops of wax.
Each book is a veritable
archaeological site
awaiting excavation.
The evidence unearthed must
be meticulously studied,
and as much as possible,
pieced together
like the tessarae of
a scattered mosaic
to try to reconstruct how nuns
fulfilled their obligations
to worship God, to
honor the Saints,
and to pray for themselves,
their fellow sisters,
and to those who were
entrusted to their care.
Such reconstructions
will invariably
be riddled with incongruities
and uncertainties and lacunae.
This would be the case,
even if all the books ever
owned by Benedictine nuns in
medieval England still survived
for analysis,
because they present
scripts intended for recitation
in not verbatim records
of performance.
And yet, given the current
state of the evidence
from their communities,
these scripts
offer the closest
witnesses that we
have to their
liturgical practices,
and thus, are privileged in
my history of those practices.
For the remainder of
my talk this afternoon
I want to acquaint you
with three manuscripts that
continually prove to be
rich sites of evidence
for my research, but have
received surprisingly little
attention from other scholars.
All of these
manuscripts were owned
by communities of Benedictine
nuns in medieval England.
And, as I will
demonstrate, they all
feature the handiwork
of female scribes
in their initial production
and/or subsequent adaptation,
even though they variously date
to the 11th and 12th centuries,
the very upper limit
of the temporal span
that scholars have determined
to be the most difficult
for identifying nuns
working as scribes.
Thus, and focusing my remarks
today on these manuscripts,
I seek to highlight
the contributions,
my own contributions to the
growing body of evidence
advancing medieval
nuns literacies,
particularly their ability to
work as copyists, collectors,
and even group
composers of text.
To this end, I will not
proceed chronologically,
but for my most
secure attribution
to more probable ones.
Spoiler alert, I have not
exhumed the bodies of any nuns
with ink stained
teeth, but I am hoping
that my findings will
encourage archaeologists
to go out digging.
The first manuscript now
held at the Bodleian Library
at the University of
Oxford under the shelf
marked Bodley 451 is a
book that was produced
in the early 12th
century at Nunnaminster,
or St. Mary's abbey in
Winchester for collation.
That is the evening gathering
of the entire monastic community
in the cloister after
vespers and before compline
at which the abbess or
prioress read aloud selections
from the scriptures,
commentaries, or homilies
on the scriptural elections
of the day, Saints
lives, commentaries on
the Benedictine rule,
or an edifying word
of her own devising.
Nunnaminster had been
founded in around 900
near the seat of West Saxon
Royal Power in Winchester
at the initiative of Queen
Ealhswith, the widow of King
Alfred.
But its construction
was completed
by her son, Edward the Elder,
in the early years of his reign.
One of Edward's
daughters, Eadburgha,
was given to the community
as a child oblate
at the age of three.
And upon her death, was buried
there and venerated as a Saint.
Throughout its
history, which endured
until its dissolution
in 1539 by Henry VIII,
Nunnaminster enjoyed
generous benefactions
of lands and movable
wealth for royalty
and high ranking nobility.
Beginning under the reign of
William I after the Norman
conquest of England in 1066,
the abbess of Nunnaminster
ranked as barren
ex-officio bearing
the responsibilities of
raising levees in times of war
and providing knight
service to the king.
Extent narrative sources attest
to the presence of a school
at the abbey, which educated
its members and other women
in its care to attain
high levels of literacy
in both reading and writing.
Bodley 451 provides
clear evidence
to support the claims
of these sources.
Bodley 451 contains Smaragdus
of Saint-Mihiel, Crown of Monks,
selections from Isidore
of Seville's, Three Books
of Sentences, a miscellany of
17 sermons mostly by Caesarius
of Arles, but also by Augustine,
Pseudo-Augustine, Maximus
of Turin, and Peter Chrysologus,
and an account of a miracle
performed by Eadburgha, the
daughter of Edward the Elder
that I mentioned before.
Nearly the entirety
of the book was
copied by a single scribe,
who wrote an illegible Anglo
Caroline minuscule and
left generous space
between each line.
The size and layout
of the page coupled
with the legibility of the
text made this book well suited
to public instruction.
The addition of accent marks
and supplemental punctuation
by a later scribe would have
enhanced the text legibility.
These additions occur
primarily in the 17 sermons
included in the book.
Most of the sermons
are longer in length
than the chapters of either
Smaragdus' Crown of Monks
or Isidore sentences.
And some lectures may have
required additional performance
cues for the modulation
of their voice
to help make the readings more
intelligible to their audience.
So interrogative sentences that
originally ended in a punctus,
or a point indicating
a pause, were
changed to punctus
interrogative, or question
marks, again, to help the reader
know when to elevate her voice.
But also, we see the addition
of punctus versus, which
look like semicolons,
which help to set off
a quotation from
scripture or when
the speaker is
supposed to assume
a voice for rhetorical effect.
Gibbet paragraph marks were
also inserted into a few texts
probably to break the sermon
into smaller sense units
or to designate passages
of particular import
to the community.
The paragraph marks
added on folio 98 verso
to one of Caesarius
of Arles sermons
on the preservation of
chastity and marriage
suggests the latter
interpretation,
because they set off
a passage affirming
the equality that women share
with men in the life of faith.
What is worse is that
these things, that
is, acts of fornication
before marriage,
are committed by many men
without any fear of the Lord,
since they are dismissed
by many in custom,
and thus are said to be cheap
and trivial so that now they
are not thought to
be serious crimes.
But in the Catholic
faith, whatever
is not entirely permitted to
women is not permitted to men.
For both men and women, too,
are redeemed with one price,
that is, with the
precious blood of Christ.
In one faith they are called,
and in one body of the church
they are gathered.
Caesarius' admonition that
the demands and rewards
of the life of faith were
the same for both sexes
offered a salutary
message to women,
irrespective of their
vocation in the church.
The nuns at Nunnaminster may
have welcomed this message,
not only for themselves but
also for the other lady that
were in their pastoral care.
The lectors of
Bodley 451 would have
been aided in the
location of specific texts
within the volume by consulting
the three tables of contents
included before
each of the three
main collections of texts.
On the slide is the
first table of contents
listing the chapters in
Smaragdus' Crown of Monks.
Page markers in
the forms of loops
of thread sewn into
the margins of the book
may have also helped to
aid in the quick location
of certain texts.
One such page marker
in purple thread
can still be found in the
bottom margin on folio 34 verso
where chapter 42 of
Smaragdus' Crown on the zeal
a pastoral office begins.
This page marker occurs at
a relative halfway point
in the 100 chapters
of the Crown.
But its addition may also
reflect the pastoral concerns
or devotional interests
of Nunnaminster's abbess
or prioress.
We can deduce that
Bodley 451 was likely
used for the instruction of the
community at evening collation
on the basis of its contents.
12th century lists of
collation from monastic houses
often included
Isidore sentences.
And in the prologue to his
Crown of Monks Smaragdus
explicitly stated that the text
was to serve as a companion
to the Benedictine
rule, recommending
that a chapter from
it be read daily
at collation to supplement
the reading from the rule
at morning chapter.
The presence of drops of wax
and wax stains on several
of Bodley 451's folio suggests
that Smaragdus' recommendation
for his text was
followed at Nunnaminster.
And so what seems clear
is that these drops of wax
indicate that the lector
brought the candle to--
brought the book too close to
a candle and that drops of wax
were then spilled on the page.
And this is likely
because the lector
was reading in a dimly
lit space or at evening.
Quite remarkably, the
main scribe of Bodley 451
included a colophon
on folio 119 verso,
immediately following
the final sermon.
Such scribal colophons
are very uncommon
before the 15th century.
But in this one the
scribe identified herself
as a scriptricks beseeching
her readers, save the scribe
and may she remain
unharmed forever.
This plea offers the
most unequivocal evidence
that we have that at least
one nun at Nunnaminster
was working as a scribe
in the early 12th century.
But there is another hand
who made marginal additions
to several folios around the
same time as the main scribe.
These additions
primarily consist
of alphabet trials and various
inscriptions, prayer verses
and lines from sermons on the
folios where they were copied.
The appearance and
content of these additions
suggest that they were made by
an inexperienced hand, perhaps
a student in the abbey school.
I must admit that
I am particularly
charmed by the repetition of the
verse from Virgil's Eclogues--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Love conquers all,
once in conjunction
with the opening line from
the Hail Mary, Ave Maria.
When I first saw
this coincidence,
I couldn't help but think of
Chaucer's Canterbury Tales
and the description
of the prioress
in the general prologue.
About her arm she bore a small--
bore of small coral
a set of beads,
adorned with large green beads.
And there on hung a
brooch of very bright gold
on which there was written
an A with a crown and after
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Evidently, the nuns of early
12th century Nunnaminster
weren't all that different
from those satirized by Chaucer
in the late 14th century.
And for those of you who haven't
had the opportunity of looking
at this gorgeous manuscript copy
of the Canterbury Tales known
as the Ellesmere
Chaucer, which includes
figures of the different
pilgrims on their way
to Canterbury.
I just have to note
that the one illuminator
responsible for the
prioress' portrait
did include the beads on her
wrist, which is just wonderful.
So the second manuscript I
wish to discuss this afternoon
is an 11th century gospel book
from Barking Abbey now held
at the Bodleian Library under
the shelf marked Bodley 155.
The remains of this community
are located just over 10 miles
east of central London.
Barking was the only community
of Benedictine nuns in England
that claimed a
continuous history
from its initial foundation
by Ethelburga and her brother
Earconwald in around 670
through to its surrender
to Henry VIII's commissioner
on November the 14th, 1539.
And though the abbey's church
cloister and surrounding
buildings were nearly
completely dismantled
in the decades following its
dissolution, textual sources,
archaeological excavations,
and GIS mapping
have helped scholars
to reconstruct
the orientation,
dimensions and features
of the monastic precinct.
Throughout its history,
Barking attracted the daughters
of royalty, nobility, and
other luminaries as members.
In 1381, Elizabeth
Chaucer, probably
a daughter of Geoffrey Chaucer,
made her religious profession
at the abbey.
Barking was located just a mile
away from St. Leonard's Priory
in Stratford, the community
led by Chaucer's prioress
in his Canterbury Tales.
Since the reign of William
I, Barking's abbess,
like Nunnaminsters, ranked
as barren ex-officio.
And at its dissolution
in 1539, Barking
was the third
wealthiest community
of religious women in England.
Bodley 155 is the only
complete gospel book
to survive from an Abbey or
Priory of Benedictine nuns
in medieval England.
It presents a unique
source of evidence
for examining nun's scribal
and liturgical practices,
because through various types
of correction and additions
it was thoroughly adapted
for public recitation.
These alterations have not
received scholarly attention.
Yet, when
systematically studied,
they offer rich insight
into the history
of the manuscripts production
and use at Barking.
The many interlinear
and marginal corrections
and additions made
to the book supply
missing narrative details,
alternative readings
for ambiguous
pronouns and phrases,
pronunciation guides,
supplemental punctuation,
neumes and other vocal
cues like passion letters.
They all indicate that it was
produced and then adapted,
not for private
devotional reading
but for communal
liturgical proclamation.
The scribes responsible
for its making
attended to the
demands of performance
on both lectors and
auditors by fashioning
a text that could announce the
good news solemnly and clearly.
The wax stains on many
of the book's folios
suggests that it was
used for the gospel
reading at the evening office
of matinees on Sundays and feast
days by the abbess of
Barking in accordance
with the dictates of
the Benedictine rule.
Due to dim lighting,
she probably
brought the book too close to a
candle, which then spilled wax
on the page.
Compared with earlier and
contemporary Anglo-Saxon gospel
books with respect to
both size and layout,
Bodley 155 is a typical
witness to the types
of books that were used
for liturgical reading.
It contains the texts of
all four gospels preceded
by their chapter
lists and prophecies,
except for Matthew's, and
that's because the manuscript
was mutilated at the beginning.
At the books end there is a
capitulary detailing the gospel
elections to be read on
different days of the week
and feast days throughout
the entire year.
The bulk of Bodley
155 was copied
by a single scribe writing
in the early 11th century,
an Anglo-Saxon minuscule.
But there were at least
seven other scribes
who worked on the production
and alteration of Bodley 155
in the 11th and
early 12th centuries.
The vast majority
of the alterations
were made by the main scribe
and a second scribe who
was writing an Anglo
Caroline minuscule not too
long afterwards.
I have categorized
their alterations
according to three types,
identification of characters,
clarification of plot, and
guides to pronunciation.
An example of the first
type of alteration
can be found on folio 37 recto.
In the inter linear
space above the verse
from the gospel of Matthew,
then the pharisees departing
formed a plan to
ensnare him in speech,
the main scribe inserted
when you read, say, Jesus.
That is instead of saying the
pronoun [NON-ENGLISH],, or him,
say, [NON-ENGLISH], or Jesus.
This substitution
would have rendered
the gospel lection
more intelligible
to an auditor,
who may have not--
who may not have known
who the him the pharisees
wished to ensnare in speech was.
The insertion of Jesus provided
the necessary identification
of the central
character in the scene.
Another kind of scribble
alteration found in Bodley 155
can be loosely grouped under the
rubric of plot clarifications.
These alterations were
made either inter-linearly
or marginally to certain
verses to provide more detail
to the gospel elections
for an auditor's benefit.
Mainly to give
greater definition
to a particular action or
object in a given scene.
A clear example of
this type of alteration
is found on folio 34 verso.
The second scribe expuncted
the verb mansit, he remained,
from the Mathieson
verse, and leaving them
he went out of the city into
Bethany and remained there,
and inter-linearly
supplied a new reading
that provides greater
specificity to Jesus' actions.
He was teaching them
about the Kingdom of God.
Different, though no less
helpful in the aural fullness
of the gospel reading
are the addition
of pronunciation guides,
supplemental punctuation,
animation, and passion letters.
A fairly thoroughgoing
re-punctuation of Bodley 155
was undertaken by
three of the scribes,
mostly by the main
scribe and second scribe.
As you can see on the
slide, through both addition
and erasure, the
punctuation was altered,
likely to help a lector
to know when to pause
or to provide certain
vocal effects to a reading.
And so here we're actually
in the gospel of Luke.
And this is actually the
parable of the prodigal son.
And you can see that the punctus
interrogative is the question
mark that was originally here.
The top part was erased
and then added down here.
So when the prodigal son
is thinking to himself--
you know, my son--
how many servants
does my father have
that are receiving bread
and more well-fed than I am
and I am famished, moved
the punctuation down here
to actually include that whole
quotation from the son that's
thinking about that question.
The clearest evidence of
Bodley's 155 intended use
in the musical
declamation of the gospel
is the addition of
adiastematic neumes.
That is neumes that were
not written on staff lines
and therefore communicate
little pitch information.
As you can see in the
example on the slide,
such additions would
have helped the reader
to align the melodic inflections
to the syllables of the text
as she intoned it.
Further indications of how the
gospels were to be proclaimed
were provided through the
additions of passion letters
to the gospels of
Matthew, Luke, and John.
As you can see on
the slide, which
features the opening of the
gospel of Matthew's passion,
the main scribe
inserted the letters
T and C in the
inter-linear space.
The meanings of these
letters were multiple
depending on time and
place and change over
the course of the Middle Ages.
But during the period
when Bodley 155 was copied
and adapted, T often marked
Jesus' words and stood
for, [NON-ENGLISH],, hold,
or, [NON-ENGLISH],, slowly,
indicating that they should
be chanted with a lower voice
and at a slower speed than
the other speaking parts.
C marked the words of the
evangelists, Jesus' followers,
Pilot, and the Jews, and stood
for [NON-ENGLISH],, quickly,
or, [NON-ENGLISH],, more quickly,
indicating that they should be
chanted with a higher voice
and at a faster speed.
Thus, these passion
letters signified
how the lector was to intone
the different speaking parts.
The foregoing
discussion has shown
that the scribal
interventions in Bodley 155
transformed the gospels
into a script fit
for liturgical performance.
What I have yet to establish
is whether the scribes
who made the various alterations
were nuns at Barking.
The most suggestive
evidence in support
of an affirmative
answer to this question
is the addition made
by the second scribe
on folio 167 recto to the
[INAUDIBLE] passage recalling
the raising of Lazarus.
Next to the verse
describing the Jews
who visited Lazarus' sister Mary
to hear and see for themselves
the miracle Jesus had
worked the second scribe
included the seemingly
absent Martha in the scene
by supplying et martham, and
Martha, in the outer margin.
At first glance,
such an addition
may seem unsurprising, given
that Martha is repeatedly
mentioned in the
preceding verses,
but she rarely makes
such an appearance
in extant bibles, gospel
books, and lectionaries
produced earlier than or
contemporary with Bodley 155.
The rarity of this
reading, thus,
begs the question
whence the inspiration
for the second scribes edition.
As Giles Constable has
shown, Martha and Mary
served as potent figures of both
the active and contemplative
lives for lay and
religious of both sexes
in the patristic and medieval,
theological, liturgical and
artistic traditions.
Yet, in medieval England,
Barking was especially
devoted to Martha.
Among extant liturgical books
from Benedictine communities,
Martha's liturgical
veneration was
noted in only one,
the calendar opening
Barking's early 15th
century ordinal, which lists
her commemoration on July 29th.
The addition of Martha to the
account of her brothers raising
then seems to inscribe
the liturgical practices
of a particular community
and the devotional interests
of a scribe fully embedded
within that community.
It may just reveal the
hand of a nun trained
in informed by Barking's
[INAUDIBLE] prayer.
But we also know
of a Barking nun
who was operative as a
scribe during the very time
that Bodley 155 was produced.
In his [? lives of
Barking's abbesses,
?] Ethelburga and Wolfhilde,
Goscelin of Saint-Bertin,
the renowned peripatetic Flemish
hagiographer of English Saints
writing in the second half of
the 11th century repeatedly
mentioned a woman named
Wulfruna Judith who was a member
of the community during
Wolfhilde's abbessy in the late
10th century, but lived
well into the second half
of the 11th.
Wulfruna Judith not only served
as the abbey sacristan helping
to organize the
community's liturgies,
but also as a scribe.
So memorable were her
deeds as a scriptricks
that Gosselin deemed it fitting
to remember her as such.
In his life of
Ethelbruga, Gosselin
recalled the story of the
infamous theft and miraculous
recovery of a missile that
Wulfruna Judith had copied.
For those who don't
know, a missile
is a type of
liturgical book that
contains all of the texts
needed to celebrate the masses
throughout the entire year.
The Barking community treasured
Wulfruna Judith's missile,
prominently displaying
it on the altar dedicated
to its founder,
Ethelburga, because it
was the abbey's optimus
codex, or best book
according to Gosselin, who must
have seen and handled the book
himself during his
time at Barking.
There is no explicit
evidence in Bodley 155
that would allow us to
identify Wulfruna Judith as one
of the scribes behind the
book's production and adaptation
for liturgical use.
However, as a scribe active
in copying liturgical books
at barking and as an officer
instrumental to the community's
liturgies, she
certainly would have
been capable of
performing such tasks.
The third and final manuscript
that I wish to acquaint you
with this afternoon--
I'll be a bit more briefly
than the preceding two--
is a 12th century Psalter
once owned by Wherwell Abbey,
but now preserved in
special collections
in the library of
St. John's College
at the University of Cambridge.
It's manuscript C 18.
Wherwell was located in
the county of Hampshire,
about 10 miles Northwest
of Nunnaminster.
The abbey was founded
in around the year 1000
by Queen Elfthryth, the
third wife of King Edgar.
A charter later issued by
her son King Ethelred II
credits her with possessing
and diligently building up
the abbey while she was alive.
An unnamed daughter of
Ethelred's was the abbess
of the house in the
mid 11th century.
In 1051, her brother
King Edward the Confessor
had his wife Edith
imprisoned at the abbey.
In 1141, Wherwell's
fortunes were nearly
completely devastated when at
the height of the Civil War
between King Stephen
and Empress Matilda
the former's troops
set fire to the church
where the community
had sought refuge.
It would take nearly 50 years
for the abbey to recover fully
from this event.
Instrumental to the reversal
in Wherwell's fortunes
were the efforts of Matilda
[INAUDIBLE],, a young widow
and daughter of a
Flemish lord who
ruled as abbess of the community
from around 1174 to 1212.
None of the abbey's
buildings still stand today.
They were destroyed after
Henry VIII's dissolution
of the community in 1539.
One of the few artifacts to
survive from abbess Matilda's
tenure in office
is this psalter,
which includes an opening
prayer for an abbess
to use to consecrate the
offering of the songs,
a calendar, the first 14
verses of the Gospel of John,
the psalter proper
beginning imperfectly,
the biblical canticles,
creeds, and our father,
a litany with
petitions, 50 prayers,
including 4 to the Trinity, a
little office of the Virgin,
and an office of the dead.
At least 19 different
scribes were
operative in the
making of this psalter,
beginning with the two who
copied the calendar, songs,
and prayers in a
Romanesque script
sometime in the late
1160s or early 1170s.
Once the psalter was in abbess
Matilda's possession, most
likely when she became abbess
of Wherwell in around 1174,
another scribe also writing
in Romanesque script
added this prayer of
confession for an abbess
on two [? bifolia ?] that
were inserted into the ante
penultimate choir.
This same scribe also altered
some of the grammatical forms
in the preceding prayers so
that it scripted a woman instead
of a man as its supplicant.
And actually you can see
the changes made here.
So these two
adjectives originally
ended in masculine
endings and they were
changed to feminine endings.
And actually, so forceful
was the corrector to the text
that there's actually a
little hole that you can
detect right behind the A here.
In the early 13th century,
a different scribe
added to the opening fly
leaf, a prayer for an abbess
to say prior to
reciting all 150 psalms
as an intercessory offering.
And on two [? bifolia ?]
appended to the book
this scribe copied an
office of the dead,
a ritual of remembrance
that supplemented
the hours of sung prayer at
vespers, matinees, and lauds.
And on May 11th of the calendar,
which actually is my birthday
too, which is another
thing, this scribe
recorded the obituary of
Matilda's maternal uncle, Osto
de Saint-Omer, who was
also a Flemish descent,
but that had
traveled around much
of Western Europe and the
Levant as a member, then
provincial master, and finally
a worthy of the Knights Templar
until his death in around 1174.
In a forthcoming
article in speculum,
I make the case for
Osto's patronage
in ownership of the psalter
before it was given to Matilda.
The 15 other scribes
who made editions
to the psalter at various times
throughout the 13th century
entered in the calendar
additional Saint's feast days
and obituaries of relatives,
community members,
and veiled religious and
clerics in Wherwell's
spiritual network.
As you can see on the
slide, the death anniversary
of abbess Matilda was
added on December 13th
sometime after
her death in 1212.
There isn't conclusive
evidence within the psalter
itself to prove that some
of the nuns of Wherwell
were responsible for making the
various alterations to the book
after it came into abbess
Matilda's possession.
However, there is
additional evidence
from the abbey that
indicates that the nuns there
were capable of creating
original literary compositions.
On the final folio of a
liturgical calendar that
was owned by Wherwell
by the late 12th century
11 elegiac couplets
commemorating the death
of abbess Matilda were copied.
These couplets offer
an important witness
to the literary skills of
the community's members
in the early 13th century,
because these verses were most
likely copied by one of
Matilda's fellow sisters,
perhaps by her niece and
successor Euphemia de
[INAUDIBLE].
The 7th through 9th
couplets read, "Matilda,
by disposition a
mother, by merits
a matron, although not a virgin
by flesh, she was a virago.
Married to a man without
the offspring of men,
she sent him ahead, and
laboring for Christ,
she became a parent in duty.
A jewel of her people,
and a woman in sex
only, in habits and merits
she was completely manly.
Flanders truly gave her birth,
England, rule, Wherwell,
an end, one faithful
to see God."
If the nuns of Wherwell
could craft compositions
like this Latin
poem, then they would
have possessed the
level of literacy
necessary to make the various
alterations to the psalter.
To conclude, liturgy mattered
to communities of Benedictine
nuns-- literacy did too, that's
what I was wanting to say,
throughout the Middle Ages.
For the vast
majority of every day
their time was spent
engaged in praying the eight
hours of the divine
office, celebrating masses,
and performing the rituals
proper to a given feast,
day of the week, or
change in the community,
such as the profession
of a new member,
the death of an established
one, or the elevation in office
or sanctity of a treasured one.
Keeping time in this way.
Heeding the steady
rhythm of the days,
months, seasons, and years
of the liturgical calendar
form the identities
of the nuns who
observed it, both as
individuals and as a collective.
Essential to the
process of formation
in a particular community
were the prayers and readings
they recited, the
chants they intoned,
the other sounds
they made and heard,
the spaces they moved
through and into
and animated and the objects
they saw, war, handled,
consumed, venerated,
transformed, and were
in turn transformed by.
Scholars interested in
studying Benedictine nuns
must first, to endeavor, to
recompose the communal ritual
practices to which these women
daily committed themselves.
And they must do so
through the very books
they produced and used,
because these objects were
the primary matter
of their liturgies.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]